36 lits transformer en lits de médecine
le troisième étage de la clinique korian
le grand parc de guyancourt qui est
normalement consacré aux soins de suite
et réadaptation est réservé depuis
quelques mois aux patients qu'aux vie de
plus et aux patients non qu'ovide mais
qui ont besoin de plus de soins il faut
imaginer que dans un étage de médecine
il faut doubler les effectifs que l'on a
en temps normal dans un soins de suite
et de réadaptation
il a fallu trouver des médecins des
infirmiers des aides-soignants et il a
fallu investir également dans du
matériel qu'on n'a pas peut-être en
temps normal électrocardiogramme celle
agences régionales de santé qui a
demandé à tous les établissements de
soins de suite de la région de créer des
lits de médecine pour prendre en charge
des patients le but de désengorger les
hôpitaux du département voire de la
région
c'est toute une réorganisation pour les
médecins de cette clinique qui ne
pratiquaient pas ce genre de soins avant
ses services c'est ce qu'on a mis en
place en c'est un service qui accueille
des patients au sortir d'une phase aiguë
qui ne sont pas encore stabilisés donc
qu'ils peuvent des compensées qui ont
besoin d'un ratio plus important de
soignants et de médecins parce qu'il y a
plus de surveillance cette patiente a
été hospitalisé à l'hôpital de mignot de
versailles pour une fracture ouverte de
la hanche déclaré par la suite qu vite
plus elle a donc été transféré à la
clinique de guyancourt le transfert
s'est fait par ambulance mais lyon c'est
arrivé ici on m'a gtrra était à l'entrée
on savait exactement ce que j'avais et
on m'a aiguillé tout de suite vers une
chambre isolée pour
terminer mon confinement les patients
hospitalisés ici reste entre une et deux
semaines
cette patiente qui avait une fracture à
la hanche peut bénéficier donc
maintenant des soins de suite et
réadaptation la spécialité initial de la
clinique le grand parc de guyancourt